the Turkish resort of Antalya is the
holiday paradise for hordes of German
tourists each summer it was here at the
airport to the east of the city that the
two Germans were arrested according to
airport police
why however remains unclear Germany's
reaction indignation
Chancellor Merkel announced she would
intensify her country's policies against
Turkey now we have two further people in
addition to the ten who have been
detained for political reasons we
believe that in most cases there is no
justification for this
[Music]
therefore we must react decisively
for me further negotiations over an
extension of the customs union are out
of the question under these
circumstances head of the Social
Democrats Martin Schulz who is running
for Chancellor went further demanding
that EU payments to Turkey be stopped
and calling for a travel warning longer
a question of weeks and months but of
the immediate future I think that in the
next few days we must assess how
fruitful our recent consular and
diplomatic efforts have been and if
necessary we must take steps to ensure
they do bear fruit opposition Green
Party that doesn't go far enough they
want the government to take a far
tougher stance on Ankara we're currently
building a tank factory in Turkey that's
the true face of Germany's Turkish
policies we need to send Ankara other
messages it's time for an end to
niceties we need to make it clear that
without the release of German hostages
without an end to utter one's
involvement in Germany there can be no
return to normal relations between
Germany and Turkey as yet there's been
no response from Ankara and Irwin's
government is keeping mum on the arrests
at least for now
you